[Musique]
la huitième édition du concours de slam
et danses urbaines organisé par le
département s'est déroulée ce mardi 20
juin au théâtre de champ fleuri
un concours qui vise à favoriser une
ouverture culturelle par la pratique de
danses actuelles ou par le slam qui
permet aux collégiens de s'exprimer
librement autour d'un thème le
département soutient ces événements
concernant les jeunes parce que le slam
permet aux enfants de s'exprimer
librement et peut-être aussi
et
enlevé l'an timidité comme ils sont en
goutte d'eau qui sont
c'est plus facile pour eux de s'exprimer
sont les nouvelles formes d'expression
le slam nécessite un travail d'écriture
et ce tout en un
une volonté de prise de parole avec
leurs mots qui correspondent vraiment à
le repport savoir que quand on est jeune
les mots c'est pas forcément là
la manière la plus facile de s'exprimer
donc c'est vrai qu'avec l'art comme la
danse ou bien encore par la musique avec
c'est vraiment plus facile pour nous
l'effervescence et la créativité était
au rendez vous douze collèges des quatre
coins de l'île sont montés sur scène des
prestations parfois poignante sur les
thèmes de l'homosexualité ou encore du
harcèlement scolaire
chacun avait son propre sujet de ce qu'à
un seul
contre l'homophobie
[Musique]
monsieur l'amour
c'était sur le harcèlement parce qu'il
ya beaucoup trop de gens qui meurent à
cause de ça et on a voulu un peu
sensibilisé les gens par rapport à ce
sujet ça nous tenait à coeur
c'est aussi qu'on prend du plaisir
le jury aura fort à faire pour
départager tous les artistes en herbe
présents des collégiens qui d'année en
année font preuve de créativité et
d'originalité
[Musique]